on this friday night a new tool in the
fight against covid19
a new cobit 19 notification app is ready
for download
what will it do and will enough
canadians get it i would be comfortable
downloading this myself they're not
collecting any personal information no
geo location data
nothing taking the temperature of
canada's economic health there are signs
the economy is on the mend
what will it take to fully recover plus
a crisis within the crisis
for american health care workers i went
through food donation
food drive lines grocery money was tight
scores of frontline workers laid off as
u.s
hospitals bleed cash during the pandemic
and a race against time off the bc coast
rescuers fight to free three entangled
humpback whales
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
it was promised long ago and prime
minister justin trudeau chose today to
announce the rollout of an app
designed to alert people if they've been
in contact with someone
who has tested positive for covid19 it's
only available
in ontario for now and the government
says it is not a contact tracing app
it's called an exposure notification app
health experts say that if enough people
sign up this app
can help prevent future outbreaks of
covet 19 in canada
abigail beeman explains how the app is
supposed to work and how the government
is reassuring canadians their privacy
will be protected
did you know that your smartphone can
help limit the spread of covid19
it's called covid alert it runs on
bluetooth exchanging codes with other
phones
and the government promises location and
personal data won't be tracked
it doesn't connect collect your name
your address your geolocation
or any other personal information i've
downloaded the app this morning
canada's privacy commissioner says he'll
use the app too
in a joint statement he and ontario's
commissioner say they support the app
but there must be ongoing monitoring and
they warn there is still a risk
third parties could try to make users
disclose information
including exposures i don't put a lot of
merit into that
because the information that is retained
is only retained for 15 days
it's not identifiable and kavukian is a
former
three-term privacy commissioner apple in
the province of ontario
asked her to weigh in before roll out
believe it or not because i'm usually so
critical of everything
this is an amazing app so what this is
balancing is the public health benefit
versus our privacy implications so it is
not maximizing the potential public
health benefit
richard lachman says it's a good balance
but it needs a lot of
uptake to be a success there was a study
by oxford university with
in their estimate it needs to be 60
percent of smartphone owners
in a country need to download it to get
the maximum benefit
in the some of the countries where this
has been tried we are nowhere near those
numbers
the government wouldn't say what the
download goal is but stresses it's not a
replacement for contact tracing
contact tracing will still need to be
done
right now by local public health
departments
officials are asking people everywhere
to download it now
but only in ontario will you get a
one-time
key you can enter in the app if you test
positive
for covid19 abigail back to questions
about the we
charity the prime minister testified
yesterday he gave no preferential
treatment to we
which we know has close ties to his
family and he said he pushed back when
he first heard we was being considered
for the contract to run
that student grant program so due
diligence could be done yet the contract
wasn't warded and he's being
investigated for breaking conflict of
interest rules
so what do diligence is he talking about
well donna trudeau was asked about that
several times today and he was clear the
due diligence he
asked for was to make sure we was the
only organization that could deliver the
program
but he didn't explain why he felt
confident enough to sit at the cabinet
table after that briefing
in terms of a perception of a conflict
of interest and ethics issue
separate from the program itself trudeau
also seemed frustrated to be
questioned about we in the first place
listen carefully to this answer
challenges
that have followed for the we
organization and indeed the
questions that have been asked of this
government have been
disappointing because it gets in the way
of the help
that we've focused on doing for for for
young people
but the opposition continues to push
this issue there's a new call for
documents and information about what
conversations the prime minister's
office had with we
as two committees keep investigating
donna
all right abigail beeman in ottawa
thanks
the prime minister made several other
pandemic related announcements today
including nearly 59 million dollars to
help temporary foreign workers
on canadian farms advocates have been
calling for
greater health and safety measures after
repeated outbreaks of covid19 among
temporary foreign workers
more than one thousand in canada have
tested positive for covid19 and
three are known to have died from it
this will fund
more farm inspections provide emergency
relief when needed
and improve the overall living
conditions on farms
the prime minister also says the
temporary foreign worker program will be
reviewed
to find ways to improve it there is news
today too about what happens after the
canada emergency response benefit or
serve
ends this fall more than eight million
canadians who lost their jobs or were
unable to find work because of the
pandemic
have applied for the two thousand dollar
a month payment the prime minister says
people relying on it will transition to
employment
insurance benefits this fall and he says
a traditional parallel benefit will be
available for people who don't qualify
for ei
such as contract and gig workers it will
include access to training and the
ability to work more hours without a
steep clawback in benefit payments
the prime minister also says there will
be a sickness and caregivers benefit for
people who get covid19 and don't have
sick leave or if a family member gets
sick and needs care
ottawa is also extending the canada
emergency commercial rent assistance
until the end of august it's the rent
subsidy program
thousands of small businesses are
relying on
well plenty of people are still out of
work but the canadian economy is
beginning to heal from the damage caused
by the pandemic
stats canada says the gross domestic
product grew by more than
four percent in may as businesses began
to reopen
that's far better than most economists
predicted though as eric sorenson
explains the economy is a long way from
even close
to normal after the near total shutdown
last spring the economy has begun
accelerating again
construction up almost 18 in may
retail sales were up 16 percent the
biggest monthly expansion for both
industries
in decades in ordinary times that would
be astounding
but in 2020 it's a modest bounce back
the overall canadian economy up 4.5
percent in may
was better than economists expected but
that's a staggering 15 percent below
what it was in february before the
pandemic hit
even with the recovery in may and a
further rebound in the numbers in june
it seems like we're still a far way off
from where we'd like to see the economy
tracking much of the economy is like
that
better but not where it once was we're
super glad that we can get back up and
running
sydney lonnie says the green eggplant is
enjoying a sharp rise in business with
expanded patios
but even as dining inside opens up with
distancing they can only
serve half the customers they did before
it's really frustrating
as to that we can't see the amount of
customers
inside the restaurant as we could before
because we're trying so hard to
practice all of the safety protocols
while some businesses mount a comeback
others have shuttered david's tease is
closing most of its stores across the
country
you're seeing bankruptcies why is that
well it's because
underlying demand is weak or in other
words people simply aren't spending
as much money as they were before while
the economy has picked up
some businesses are far from normal and
will not get back to normal for months
or even years
air canada is reporting a 1.75 billion
dollar loss
in the second quarter passenger numbers
down 96 percent from a year ago
inside canada's atlantic bubble one
premier hopes to open up to more travel
it's not just people coming to this
province to come to visit and see
beautiful places they're coming actually
to do transactions
so we have to get to the point where
we're going to be living with covet
and we can't continue to lock ourselves
down economists say the key to economic
growth is keeping virus case numbers low
so canadians will feel comfortable
traveling and just going out to spend
their money
eric sorensen global news toronto
just ahead of the long weekend some
public health restrictions in toronto
and the peel region have been lifted
those regions join most of the rest of
ontario in stage three of that
province's reopening plan
it means gyms and movie theaters and
playgrounds can reopen
people can dine inside bars and
restaurants not just outside on the
patios
indoor gatherings of up to 50 people are
now allowed and outdoor gatherings of up
to 100.
ontario's premier warns the province is
not out of the woods though and people
need to remain
vigilant a month ago
our neighbors in the u.s were heading
into the july 4th long weekend
the numbers were down school schools
were set to open in four to six weeks
bars and restaurants were reopening that
long weekend
people went to parties beaches and
gatherings
acting like coveted 19 was over
you just have to look at what happened
since then
to know how devastating it has been
windsor essex is now the only part of
ontario that remains in stage two of the
reopening it continues to have
the highest rate of covid19 in ontario
nova scotia reported two new covid19
cases today its first new infections
in over two weeks a new requirement to
wear masks in most indoor public spaces
comes into effect today though the
province is taking an honor system
approach
to that policy and new brunswick is
expanding its bubble
a little bit ross lord has an update on
the kobit 19 health measures in atlantic
canada
at this fitness center in dartmouth nova
scotia customers don't get in unless
they wear a mask
you have to wear the face mask as soon
as you enter the building in any public
spaces from the welcome desk to the
hallways
to the locker rooms in a province where
new covet 19 cases have been scarce
recently
making indoor masks mandatory could keep
the virus away
people like karen decali can still
exercise without wearing a mask wear it
on the way in
in all the common areas they said it's
okay if you don't wear it
while you're working out but make sure
to wear it in the common areas
in neighboring new brunswick there are
also new rules that province
is expanding the atlantic bubble
allowing visits from a select number of
communities in quebec
not only are these only day passes but
you have to register in advance so we
know where you are
back in nova scotia the mandatory mass
policy has plenty of supporters
we don't know when there's going to be a
second wave of october 19 and we have to
cover ourselves just if you're a senior
like me
but the province has decided not to
enforce the rule
so there's no penalty for breaking it i
think there should be a fine i think
that's really the only thing that will
work
we shouldn't need to have a strong
compliance
and enforcement approach to to have
people
do the right thing more adjustments as
canadians follow the moving target of
pandemic rules
ross lord global news dartmouth nova
scotia
there's still lots of hope riding on a
vaccine and today america's top
infectious disease doctor
said there are no guarantees but he's
cautiously optimistic one could be ready
for distribution in the u.s
by the end of the year dr anthony fauci
appeared before a congressional
subcommittee investigating the u.s
response to the pandemic
he also pushed back against claims based
on one study that the anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine
is effective against covid19
the henry ford hospital study that was
published
was a non-controlled retrospective
cohort study
that was confounded by a number of
issues so that study is a flawed study
and i think anyone who examines it
carefully
is that it is not a randomized
placebo-controlled trial
it's a statement it doesn't matter you
can peer review something that's a bad
study
fauci says all the valid scientific data
shows hydroxychloroquine
is not effective in treating the virus
his comments come a day after president
donald trump said
he still thinks it works against covid19
in demand but out of work coming up the
unexpected impacts of this pandemic
on american healthcare workers plus an
enormous task off dc's coast the race to
save
three entangled humpback whales
in the u.s health care workers are on
the front lines of the worst outbreak of
covid19
in the world they're in demand more than
ever but
in the midst of that tens of thousands
of nurses
are being laid off private for-profit
hospitals are facing a dire financial
crisis
jackson prescott reports it's an
unprecedented challenge
in the midst of a national health crisis
american health care workers face an
unexpected problem
unemployment when this first came out i
was i was ready to put on my boots and
go out into it
instead nurse dana james was shocked to
see her hours cut
as the virus ravaged new york and new
jersey in march
the florida hospital where she works sat
empty
cleared out to make room for patients
who never came
soon after she was laid off it doesn't
bring me shame but i went through
food donation food drive lines i loaded
the kids up and
grocery money was tight by april an
estimated 1.5 million health care
workers in the u.s had lost their jobs
hospitals canceled money-making elective
surgeries to free up beds for covid19
patients
emergency room visits dropped off as
people stayed home
like any other business for-profit
hospitals looked to cut
costs a lot of hospitals are quiet about
cutting
nurses hours right i mean because who
wants to say during a worldwide pandemic
that you're cutting nurses hours
it's estimated american hospitals have
lost a combined 50 billion dollars per
month
every month since march that was just
the first wave
and as the pandemic ramped up and as
patients started showing up
the costs of treatment spiraled
hospitals went from empty to overwhelmed
forced to buy ppe ventilators and extra
beds
well i think what we're seeing
particularly in the united states is
we're seeing a
system of care that really doesn't act
as a system these are individual
hospitals individual doctors individual
insurance companies
and suppliers all acting in their own
best interests
jobs have been slow to return even as
cases of the virus surpass
4 million it's turned around somewhat
but it hasn't returned
to pre-covered levels
long-term there are fears the financial
crisis gripping the health industry will
lead to a labor shortage
hospitals and clinics could be driven
out of business right now it's ugly
it's it's like nothing i've seen before
today dana james is back on the job
in fact she's busier than ever it kind
of is
it's an eye opener to see how our
country has
dealt with us compared to other
countries and how we're developing
comparing us to the rest of the world
her only worry now treating patients who
may never understand the toll the virus
has taken
on those providing care jackson proskow
global news
washington
still ahead a big change in hong kong's
upcoming elections
you're watching global national
[Music]
hong kong has announced it's delaying
its upcoming elections
they were scheduled to take place in
september but have been
pushed back a year hong kong's leader
kerry lam says politics was not
involved she says it's been done to
protect people's health
hong kong is at a surge in kovid 19
cases since the beginning of july
the election delay is a blow to the
pro-democracy opposition that was hoping
to capitalize on
rising anti-beijing sentiment
there's also been an increase in cases
in parts of the uk and the government
has delayed plans to ease public health
restrictions
casinos bowling alleys and other venues
were supposed to open tomorrow
that's not happening now wedding
receptions and indoor concerts are also
on hold again
the uk is expanding its mandatory face
covering rule to include museums
cinemas and places of worship the
measures will be reviewed again
in two weeks next the case for easing
canada's border restrictions
for couples
off the bc coast rescuers are working
hard to save three humpback whales
tangled in fishing gear
this one was spotted near vancouver
island it has a trap and line running
through its mouth
trying to remove it takes caution and
patience
rescuers say the trap is very close to
the whale's body and the gear will be
difficult to cut off
two other humpbacks caught in lines and
netting have also been spotted
the department of fisheries and oceans
says entanglements like this happen
every year but
it's unusual to get so many at once
the border between the united states and
canada has been closed to non-essential
travel now since march
21st and no public health officers in
this country want it to open anytime
soon
that's left some couples separated
longer than they ever expected
the travel exemptions only include
partners who are married or common law
and as mike drollet reports a canadian
doctor is petitioning to change that
in the name of love
welcome to canada not recently the
border remains closed but to a select
few
when that will change could come down to
trust the challenges are
are people actually adhering to
quarantine and those
those rules epidemiologist ashley tweet
ran the numbers
if the u.s continues to have 75 000 new
cases per day
44 infected americans would cross for
every 25 000 travelers
keep the border closed to non-essential
traffic and that number dips
considerably
the bottom line is if the u.s can get
below 10 000 new daily cases
the risk will be manageable what she
fears
is the so-called super spreader a single
infectious person who can transmit the
virus to dozens
or even hundreds of other people so
every case that we're importing
has the potential to to spark an
outbreak so that that's where the
concern lies
and that's science what's missing says
dr david edward ue poon
is the humanity when his girlfriend
alexandria aquino landed in toronto from
ireland
she was turned away the exemptions for
travel
don't include partners unless they're
married or common law
poon submitted a petition not to have
the border reopened
but to have the exemptions expanded we
are willing to sign
a sworn affidavit we are willing to put
ourselves legally and financially
bound to that concept in response to a
question from global news
the federal government intimated it's
happy with the exemptions as they stand
but ndp mp brian massey says that
doesn't fly
in 2020. we shouldn't just define it by
a
basically a nuclear family example from
the 1950s
what we need to do is be more modern
about the approach here
modern like the long long-distance
relationship between floridian
giana formica and her montreal boyfriend
jean-christophe blay
they've been together for a year and a
half but for all their dreams
their future is in the hands of
politicians
you know i would take all those safety
precautions and they can knock on
the door they can check on me i don't
care i just want to be
with the person i love for that to
happen it seems science
is going to have to make room for trust
mike relay global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen we'd like to
say eid mubarak to all of you
celebrating eid al-adha
it's being celebrated differently this
year by muslims all over the world
because of the pandemic
no more praying shoulder to shoulder
hundreds of people were invited inside
this stadium in dublin so they had
enough room to maintain physical
distance
in illinois these worshipers also kept
their distance by praying
in a parking lot thanks for watching
take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye